hi I'm Eric Voss and we've been getting
new updates about the upcoming venom
movie with spider-man's best villain
getting this own solo film produced by
Sony Tom Hardy will be playing venom
slash Eddie Brock and freaking carnage
is gonna be playing the villain so venom
and carnage together in a movie is a
huge deal and this is probably why Sony
announced that this movie will
definitely be rated R and this R rating
is interesting because it brings in a
question how venom and carnage could
never fit into the overall cinematic
universe of Marvel characters with the
MCU known as pretty family-friendly
versions of these superheroes and
villains
now even though Sony and Marvel Studios
are partnering to allow spider-man as a
character to cross over to the MCU and
with movies like spider-man Home Coming
Marvel head Kevin Feige has made it
clear that this will not be the case for
the venom movie so it sounds like venom
and carnage will be in their own
separate movie universe where maybe
spider-man might appear according to Amy
Pascal of Sony but venom won't appear in
scenes with or even really reference MCU
characters like Iron Man Captain America
Thor or whole now at first this seems
like kind of a bummer because these guys
have a lot of fun interactions with all
these other Marvel characters in the
comics but I think this could ultimately
be a good thing why because venom needs
to have an R rating he is a violent
monstrous killer carnage even more so
and I just don't see Marvel Studios in
the direction that it's currently going
being willing to adapt venom and carnage
to screen in their true terrifying forms
so let's talk about venom and carnage
why there's such great villains and why
keeping them out of the Marvel side of
the Cinematic Universe might be the best
thing for them and potential spoiler
warning in case any of my speculation
with stuff from the comics ends up being
in the movie so let's start with a
little background on venom venom comes
from an alien race of symbiotes who in
the comics he attaches himself to
spider-man when he was in battle world
which is a big melee with a ton of
different superheroes and villains so
Peters suit was damaged and the symbiote
covered his body giving him this new
awesome black suit with a white logo it
also had a shape-shifting ability
allowing him to mimic wearing street
clothes and it gave him an unlimited and
stronger supply of webbing but then
Peter learned that the symbiote was
really a parasite that eventually drains
all the adrenaline from its host so he
detached it using these
like waves from the bells in a church
bell tower and then the symbiotes sought
out another person who hated Peter
Parker ex journalist Eddie Brock who's
career Peter ended and it merged with
Eddie Brock creating venom now some of
this back story was adapted for the
version of venom that we saw in
spider-man 3 with Topher Grace and
unfortunately that movie didn't really
do nearly enough with the character
spider-man 3 really just mostly stuck
with Peters relationship with a symbiote
which turned him into a kind of pervy
dancer with the Eddie Brock venom
subplot getting lost in Peters conflict
with Harry Osborn and Sandman and as
much as I love to watch James Franco
eating pie I'd rather see venom do some
messed-up [ __ ] and this is why I'm
excited about this r-rated venom movie
venom is savage a big part of his
popularity is that he's very much a
bizarro version of spider-man and sorry
to mix in a DC reference a man like
Peter Parker is super friendly and
neighborhoody he's a kid he cracks jokes
but venom is a total monster since he
previously bonded with spider-man as a
symbiote all later versions of venom
have spider-man's powers too he's a lot
stronger and he's a shapeshifter
and he's invisible to spider-man spidey
sense making him a serious threat in
fact in the comics he's considered by
shield to be one of the biggest dangers
to all of humanity
up there with Magneto and dr. doom and
already you just can't do that character
justice with a pg-13 MCU type movie that
you would take little kids to go see
unless you want them to grow up to be
cool and the director currently attached
to venom is ruben fleischer who directed
zombie land and I really hope that he
brings that same dark violent sense of
humor to this movie too now I actually
kind of like Sam Raimi's design of the
symbiote and spider-man 3 but I think
Fleischer can build on that to make
venom even more monstrous and
stomach-turning
I'm just gonna give you a few examples
of some of the sickening stuff that
venom has done in various versions of
the comics one later host of venom Mac
Gargan formerly the Scorpion isn't as
good as Eddie Brock is at controlling
the symbiote so he gives in to some of
the more animalistic urges specifically
cannibalism yes venom freakin eats
people
and that same version of venom also gets
in a fight with bullseye who throws a
small dog into Venom's eye and venom
continues fighting with the dogs
sticking out of his eye until later he
pops it out and Chuck's it now another
version of venom did
choose from a host who's a mobsters son
Angelo Fortunato in the middle of a jump
between buildings he lets the guy fall
to his death then there's a really bad
version of the venom comics from the
mid-2000s where venom fights with the
thing from the Fantastic Four and he
kills him by sticking his long tongue
down his throat and then there's another
alternate series of Marvel Comics called
what-if where the battle world arc that
I mentioned earlier goes a different way
and spider-man is on a planet with his
symbiote black suit but then he gets hit
with a sonic blast and the symbiote
detaches from Peter Parker's skeleton
that's right Peter Parker had been dead
for years and the symbiote form of venom
was just weakened at Bernie and his
corpse all this time but really it's not
just this insane creative violence that
makes venom a more adult character and
yeah it isn't profanity either it's the
sex I'm kidding guys I really don't want
to see venom have sex
I really shouldn't brought up that
example with the thing really it's the
deeper psychological component of venom
as a character now as a symbian bonded
with a host there's kind of a split
personality competing for control of
Eddie Brock's mind it's a toxic balance
of the two organisms hatred feeding and
enabling each other and that was another
element that the spider-man 3 venom just
didn't have enough time to go into
really I don't know how far the MCU
would be willing to explore that kind of
psychological disorder like Iron Man 3
kind of touched on Tony Stark's PTSD
from the battle in New York I guess dr.
strange looked at Stephens depression
after his car accident but the competing
voices in Eddie Brock's head are
something that he has to deal with in a
very physical way and that's a conflict
that's gonna take a lot of maturity and
patience to convey on screen for example
look at Logan director James Mangold
said that the R rating for that movie
wasn't just so he could show Wolverine
clawing through skulls even though that
was very cool and I'm glad I got to see
it mangled said that he wanted to
explore characters and relationships in
a way that didn't also have to please
audiences with shorter attention spans
so that's why huge sections of Logan's
simply focus on the mental emotional and
physical toll that superpowers have
taken on Logan and Charles there are
people not toys they get sick they
aren't always likable and spoiler alert
seriously stop watching if you haven't
seen Logan they kiss just kidding they
die now I don't always need my superhero
movies
oh that deep into a character's
psychological trauma like thor ragnarok
looks like ridiculous fun and i would be
kind of bummed if it ever got this
serious but in Venom's case yeah i
really think it needs to be more
emotionally complex and I really think
Tom Hardy is perfect for that kind of
raw physical role he's a serious actor
who puts his whole body into a
performance I just hope that for this
super hero villain he'll pick a
different voice your spider sense won't
save you now Barca but let's move on to
carnage the villain of this movie yeah
that's right
carnage is so awful that even venom sees
them as a threat that needs to be
stopped so a little background on
carnage in the comics the carnage is the
asexual offspring of Venom symbiote and
it attaches to Cletus Kasady who's a
serial killer whom Eddie Brock shares a
prison cell with and Cassidy is already
totally evil as a kid he tortured his
family dog with an electric drill and he
killed his grandmother by pushing her
down a flight of stairs he also burned
down the boy's home that he was forced
to live in so when Cassidy becomes
carnage he just goes on straight-up
killing sprees just to get spider-man's
attention and really because he just
feels like it he murders one of Peter
Parker's classmates and he could
shape-shift his arms into cutting
weapons slicing and impaling the bodies
of innocent bystanders on the street and
in diners he attacks a little kid in a
baby in a bathtub and he kills people
through computer screens and he
constantly fantasizes about mutilating
Peter Parker so really as intense as
venom is carnage is way more extreme and
again there's just no way this would
work in anything less than an hour
rating so if Sony really plans to go in
this direction with a darker more adult
superhero movie universe separate from
the family-friendly MCU they're really
right to set the tone early with this
venom movie it really is the best way to
be true to what fans love from the
comics do you think a movie version of
venom that will never cross paths with
Iron Man or Captain America or Hulk or
for that matter daredevil or Punisher is
worth its own movie universe if net
universe gets to be dark adult and
violent and do you think venom should
use its r-rating for more extreme
violence or to explore that kind of
psychological trauma stuff on a level
that younger audiences just might not
appreciate let me know what you think in
the comments down below and share this
video on Twitter
you can tweet your thoughts directly to
me at EA boss or to new rock stars at
new rock stars and subscribe to new rock
stars in this channel to keep up with
all of our videos about spider-man and
the Marvel movies you can also
contribute to us on patreon to be more
part of our team and to have more say
and what videos we make and to access
exclusive content on our page big thanks
to our patron Kelly hopper thanks for
watching and I just thought about the
kiss again
god I can't unsee it